Hello students.
My name is Kirsten Scott.
And I am the teaching fellow for this course and absolutely honored
to be joined today by the Honorable Minister of Health of Rwanda, Dr.
Agnes Binagwaho.
So really just to get things started, I think it will be helpful to have some more context
with respect to where you call home.
Where I call home.
Home is Rwanda.
And I was privileged to come back in Rwanda and work as a pediatrician.
Because I am a pediatrician in 1996.
It was two years after the genocide against Tutsi.
And at that time, the country was still totally destroyed.
We were six pediatricians for a population of around 10 million.
And there were no drugs.
Infrastructure was destroyed across the country, as I told you.
The morale of the health workers was not there.
And the trust of the population was not there too.
Because health professional had contributed in the killing.
So people were not feeling safe on one hand.
But also there was at that time no possibility to give continuous quality care according
to what we know.
That means the knowledge, the science.
And evidence that has been built across the world.
What we have to do, we were not able to do it.
But not only that, because a doctor can do nothing alone.
We need to work with nurses.
We need infrastructure.
And as I told you, the knowledge of the people who were working in hospitals
were so little, that we were losing a lot of children
just because the basic science, the medical science, was not integrated.
So we were not in the condition to prevent care.
But the little we were providing all together was absolutely out of standard.
And it was all a process to rebuild everything.
In fact, they rebuilt the entire system.
It was really out of standards.
And you can imagine, you cannot create a society oriented to people when you
plan to kill a big part of them.
So since the year '60, when Rwanda was independent, the number of doctors educated was very few.
There were no nurses who had a degree.
It was a lower level of secondary school.
There were no books.
We just managed to build the first library two years ago.
There were not real teachers in the university.
It was people teaching like that, or friends coming and teach.
So we didn't built the capacity to provide social services to our own people.
And the little that we had has been destroyed, other people killed, other people out.
So that's the context when I came in a country devastated
by the genocide of the Tutsi, by HIV, by malaria.
So it was really a piece of land where nothing was working.